des combats âpres pour faire gagner le
bien vains jedi se sont affrontés à
voisins le bretonneux pour repousser les
forces du mal l'objectif de ce premier
championnat interclubs de sabre laser le
combat sportif au sabre laser
c'est un combat la touche 15 points
gagnés en trois minutes donc avec des
règles spécifiques on a créé dont
combats ont dîné en individuel on ne
peut pas utiliser les pouvoirs de la
force
par contre effectivement dans le combat
en équipe
là on va pouvoir s'amuser à pouvoir
lancer des pouvoirs comme des éclairs de
force
de nombreuses forces en présences ou les
stratégies se penche longuement tout ça
sous la vigilance des soldats de l'armée
impériale en patrouillant contrôle au
matin à l'ordre on a trouvé des jedi des
rebelles on a fait quelques arrestations
et j'ai plus tard voir quand j'étais
petit j'avais 7 ans le l'épisode tattoo
cinéma et ben voila je tombé dedans
quand j'étais petit et aux questions
tout peur même si c'est les méchants sa
une à une carrière passée c'est
emblématique les jedi ont ramené
l'equilibre dans la force prochain
combat le 13 décembre 2017 avec la
sortie de l'épisode 8